the day after the final a few tired fans
make their way through the streets of
London it was a big day for German
football and the British tabloids
christened by Ernst I quraían Alban man
of the match there was a lot of interest
in the German German final among British
soccer fans good because it's a foreign
teams into England to see him play but
the best teams in Europe were there but
at the end of the day they both deserve
to be there they're called money into
the British economy good for relations
with two countries Saturday evening in
London's district of Ealing 150 Dortmund
fans all from Britain watched the match
initial scenes of joy turned into
disappointment as Bayern took the lead
with a second goal shortly before the
final whistle it was the end of a
nail-biting match for the game it was
electric there was singing songs and I
was trying to sing along upstairs and
understand half of it but the atmosphere
for I was amazing Dortmund UK fan club
set the mood before the match with
German bought boston beer
organizer Benjamin macfadyen lived in
Germany for several years and he
supported Dortmund ever since very
touching from the hearts just seeing the
black and yellow boys just turning up at
the club and we've got several hundred
people there everybody's having a great
time so yeah I'm very happy there's a
lot of interest in the Bundesliga in
Britain these days soccer magazine 442
featured a german club Dortmund on the
front page for the first time earlier
this year journalist David Hall explains
why the Bundesliga is popular in Britain
think the feeling here in this country
is that fans in Germany are treated as
fans whereas here in the UK fans are
treated as customers multiple products
that needs to be sold to people so it's
a very romantic ideal the Bundesliga and
I think we all quite like it here on
Saturday afternoon Bayern fans were
clearly outnumbered on to founders
square by Dortmund fans who travelled to
London from the rest of England as well
as Scotland and Ireland
James chalon or from Lester has been
attending Dortmund games ever since he
was 18 maybe five six times the season
and I go to watch home games at the
Stalin study on in comparison to the
English game we we were able to stand we
were able to drink and I don't smoke but
my some of my friends do and they are
allowed to smoke in the stadium Phillip
Moses from London has been a Dortmund
fan since he was a kid his grandmother
knitted the sweater it's his mascot I
went for example last weekend to
Hoffenheim and I paid probably about all
together 90 euros including travel to
watch the game whereas here for 60 60
pounds you just get to see the football
so I'm you get the atmosphere included
which is absolute fantastic ever he's
talking about John refer below and for
the first time british television is
actually showing Bundesliga highlights
they've never done that before Dortmund
supporters bernadine and Patricia
traveled here from Dublin we went to
Dortmund three years ago to see Leonard
Cohen in the West fallen holla and right
next door was this beautiful stadium and
the whole town of dormant is black and
yellow and the virus just got into our
blood and I was like I want to be part
of this Dortmund fans celebrated German
football from Carnaby Street to the fan
party in Ealing
I feel like I'm a doorman support on our
behalf a German team I never really had
a favorite team but now it's going to be
dorman
the champions league final marked a
great day for the Bundesliga here in
Britain